ونحييكم من مشاهدينا الى هذه التغطيه
المستمره للازمه في السودان فبعد يوم من
اعلان الجيش وافقته على مبادره طرحتها
منظمه
الراهنه اكدت الخارجيه السودانيه
اللامفاوضات بين الجيش والدعم السريع والا
سبيل امام قوات حمايه الا الاستسلامه ومع
تضاؤل اي فرص تسويه للازمه عبر الحوار
يبدو ان المواجهات تشتد قبل ساعات على
انتهاء الهدنه المعلنه مراسل العربيه قال
ان الجيش ينفذ طلعات جويه جديده في
الخرطوم بينما يرد دعم السريع بمضادات
ارضيه اما حول الوضع الصحي المتفاقم فقد
ضع الصليب الاحمر طرفي الصرع الى تسهيل
عمل المنظمات الانسانيه في وقت تتفاقم فيه
الازمه الانسانيه جراء المواجهات ما اجبر
اعدادا كبيره على النزوح
كما ترون انه مسجد بداد السوق المركزي
تدمر نهائي كل الدكاكين اللي في السوق ما
في دكان من
قوه الانفجار وجينا
السيد البرهان والسيد حميد
نسبه لدعم الشعب وللمعاناه التي عاناها
الشعب السوداني
[موسيقى]
وفيما يخص مبادره ايجاد بشان تسويه
الاوضاع في السودان بين طرفي الصرع نفت
الخارجيه السودانيه الانبالتي تتحدث عن
تفاوض الجيش مع الدعم السريع مشيره الى
الا صحه لقبول الجيش بالتفاوض مع الدعم
السريع والا خيار امام دعم السريع سوى
الاستسلام واضافت الخارجيه السودانيه ان
قوات الدعم السريع مستمره في خروقاتها
للهدنه وتعديها على المدنيين واتخاذهم
دروعا بشريه بيان الخارجيه السودانيه
بالاعتداء على المستشفيات والمراكز الصحيه
وبتعطيل عملها
ومع استمرار المواجهات وتردي الاوضاع
الامنيه في السودان وسط استمرار عمليه
الاجلاء تستمر حركه نزوح الداخلي الى
مناطق بعيده عن مواقع للشبكات او الى دول
الجوار حيث يستمر الابلاغ عن نزوح
المدنيين في ولايه الخرطوم والولايه
الشماليه ونيل الازرق وشمال كردفان وشمال
دارفور وغرب دارفور وجنوب دارفور الى جانب
التحركات عبر الحدود الى البلدان المجاوره
وقد حذرت الامم المتحده من ان ربع مليون
سوداني قد يكونون في طريقهم للهرب برا الى
دول المجاوره ومن بين الدول السبع
المجاوره للسودان فان اهم التحركات وفق
مفوضيه اللاجئين هي نحو تشاد وجنوب
السودان المفوضيه اوضحت ان الذين شقوا
طريقهم بانفسهم الى المناطق الحدوديه مع
تشاد يقدر عددهم بنحو 20 الفا كما انها
تتوقع عبور نحو 45 الف لاجئ سوداني جديد
الى جنوب السودان والى مصر الجاره
الشماليه ذكرت المفوضيه ان لديها تقارير
عن بدء نزوح بعض النازحين الى مصر في حين
اعلنت السلطات المصريه ان الاف الاشخاص من
مختلف الجنسيات تمكنوا من الخروج من
السودان الى مصر عبر معبره قسطل وارقين
حيث يتجاوز عددهم العشره الاف شخص
[موسيقى]
الازمه في السودان موجه هجره جديده صحيفه
تيليغرافي البريطانيه تتوقع نزوح اعداد
مهوله من السكان وبالتالي زياده في عدد
المهاجرين غير النظاميين
فبريطانيا وحدها قد تشهد لجوء اعداد كبيره
من السودانيين الامم المتحده تقول ان عددا
كبيرا من اللاجئين السودانيين فروا الى
بلدان المجاوره منذ بدء الازمه مع توقعات
بنزوح مئه الف سوداني الى تشاد ومئه
وسبعين الفا الى جنوب السودان بالاضافه
الى مصر وجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
بدورها تناشد الامم المتحده جميع الدول
بجوار السودان ابقاء حدودها مفتوحه امام
الذين يبحثون عن الاماني والحمايه
[موسيقى]
هذا وكانت اظهرت مقاطع مصوره استعداد
الحافلات لعمليات النزوح من العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم هربا من الاقتتال
الدائر نتابع
وفي جديده التطورات الميدانيه رصد مراسل
العربيه خلو الشوارع في المنطقه الرابعه
بين الخرطوم بحري واندرمان مع وجود قوات
الدعم السريع في هذه المنطقه الان اقف هنا
في صينيه اسماعيل الازهري وهذا منزل اول
رئيس وزراء
في هذه المنطقه ليست ببعيده من جسر شباك
الرابط
يطلع لقوات الدعم قوات الدعوه تتمركز في
هذا الجسر الان وليس في بعيده من هذه
المرحله الطريقه الاخر من هنا يؤدي الى
الهيئه القوميه للاذاعه والتلفزيون التي
تتجدد فيها الاشتباكات في مدينه ام درمان
ربما هذه المنطقه الان كما نراها هادئه
لكن السكان هنا يشكون من هلع وتوتر بحكم
ان هذه المنطقه بالتحديد يسمع فيها اصوات
ذوي للمدافع الثقيله والخفيفه وفي هذه
المنطقه بالضبط يسمع ايضا مضادات او
طائرات بين الفينه والاخرى اصبحت خاليه
تماما من السكان الا نذرا يسيرا وهم الان
يحذروننا من الوقوف في هذه المنطقه لقناتي
العربيه والحدث سالم الهاشمي من مدينه ام
درمان
ويبقى معنا زميلنا سالم الهاشمي مراسل
العربيه من اندرمان سالم من جديد اهلا بكم
وفيتنا بهذا التقرير وفيه بعض الصور حيث
نلاحظ هدوءا ولكن تتحدث عن حاله من التوتر
وعن سماع اصوات الشبكات فهل هذه للشبكات
هي بعيده عن مركز المدينه او هي مقتصره
على بعض الشوارع حدثنا اكثر عن هذه
التفاصيل
نعم هذه المنطقه بالتفصيل هي منطقه كانت
حيويه في السابق وهي صينيه اسماعيل
الازهريه واحده من المناطق كذلك التاريخيه
لان في هذه المنطقه منزل اسماعيل الازهري
اول رئيس وزراء في تاريخ السودان لكن بعد
بدايه هذه الحرب اصبحت خاليه تماما بعد
اغلاق هذا الجسر هذا الطريق يؤدي الى
الرابط بين الضمان وبحري هذه المنطقه ظلت
مكان اشتباكات سواء في هذا الجانب او
الجانب الاخر لكن في الضفه الاخرى كانت هي
محل الاشتباكات الاكثر لانها في الضفه
الاخرى من هذا الجسر توجد او يوجد مقر من
المقرات قوات الدعم السريع وهو معسكر كان
يتبع
قبل ذلك لجهاز الامن ثم اصبح يتبع لقوات
الدعم السريع في هذه المنطقه من منطقه
المظلات او عفوا كان يتبع للمظلات ثم بعد
ذلك اصبح تابعا لقوات الدعم السريع في هذه
المنطقه شه يده الاشتباكات وشهدت قصف كذلك
في الفترات الماضيه كانت هناك طائرات
تحلق ابابيل وهي تحلق بالقرب من نهر النيل
وتقصف هذا المعسكر ادى هذا الامر الى خلع
في تلك المنطقه
مواطنون كثر ما رحلوا من هذه المناطق
وخرجوا منها هناك فقط القليل من بقي وهم
ايضا يرون ان هذه المنطقه خطره جدا وخرج
سالم
يخرجون بعيدا عن مناطق الاشتباكات بشكل
عام مثل كل حالات النزوح التي تكررت وهي
ان المواطنين يبتعدون عن مناطق الاشتباكات
اما الى اطراف اندرمان او الى خارج
الولايه تماما الى ولايات اخرى هناك من
يخرج خارجي السودان تماما هذه المنطقه
لافت ان هناك بعض السيارات بقوات الدعم
السريع تقوم بتمشيط بين الفينه والاخرى
بحسب شهود عيان في تلك المنطقه لكنهم
بالنهار يقللون هذا التمشيط ويكسر هذا
التمشيط ليلا في هذه المنطقه
طيب افتحوا قليل وكذلك حتى في تقرير
المصور الذي تبعنا تفاصيله تحدثت عن حاله
من التوتر والحذر كذلك يعيشه اهالي ام
درمان كيف ينعكس ذلك على حياتهم اليوميه
هل هناك امتناع عن الخروج هل هناك
نيه لترك المنطقه هناك مخاوف من ان تعود
الاشتباكات كيف يعيش اهالي ام درمان هذه
التطورات
نعم هل يندرمان في
بالقرب من هذه المناطق غالبيتهم خجر وهذه
المناط بحكم انها اصبحت غير امنه الى
الولايه او الى خارج الولايه تماما لكن
بعد ذلك
هناك الشكاوى والقلق والتوتر الذي هو
موجود
يدفع السكان الى عدم الاستقرار في تلك
المنطقه خوف حياتهم حرصا على
له مكروه في ظل هذا الانفلات الامني
الموجود في هذه ما في ظل انتشار ايضا
بهذه الرساله في ظل ما تبعناه من
ازدياد اسعار اتذاكر وعدم توفر المركبات
او الحافلات كيف تتم عمليات النزوح
نعم ايضا هذه واحده الاشكاليات التي تواجه
الناجحين بشكل عام مساله اسعار التذاكر
كذلك وجود الفحوصات نفسها في ظل ايضا
انعدام في الحقول هذا الوقود يضاف الى ذلك
عدم الامن في الطرق المؤديه الولايات
والشكاوى من مواطنين في مناطق مختلفه بعض
عمليات النهب والسرقه وغير ذلك كل هذه
الامور الوضع ما زال قلقا مترو
[تصفيق]
الطبيعيه كما هو في مناطق اخرى من ام
درمان نفسها
الجيش نلاحظ فيها حياه وفيها حركه شبه
طبيعيه ليس طبيعيه بالكامل
ايضا في كل المناطقة سالم اكيد وضحت هذه
النقطه ولكن بالنسبه لهذه المنطقه
والى اساسيات او الاساسيات
الضروريه الى اي مذاه هي متوفره من ما من
غذاء من تطبيب الى اخره
نعم في هذه المنطقه ليس بعيدا منها ايضا
من مستشفى ام درمان وهو مستشفى الاكبر فيه
ام درمان والمستشفى المرجع باعتبارك
ايضا شبه خالي لانه الحركه من والى الخضور
عاليه يحاول السكان الابتعاد عن مثل هذه
المواطنون يحاولون الابتعاد عن مثل هذه
المناطق فهذه اشكاله حتى تواجد الكوادر
الطبيه داخل المستشفى الحركه الى المستشفى
بالنسبه للكوادر الاوروبيه بالنسبه
لقيه العاملين كذلك في المستشفى ربما كل
هذه تجعل من الصعوبه جدا ان تكون هناك
حياه طبيعيه هناك تذبذب ايضا في خدمه
الكهرباء والمياه
طيب على كل سنبقى نرصد كل هذه التفاصيل
شكرا جزيلا لك على كل ما وفيتنا به من
معلومات سالم الهاشمي مراسل العربيه من
اندرمان شكرا لك سالم
ومشاهدينا ميدانيا اغارت مقاتلات تابعه
للجيش السوداني على مواقع لقوه الدعم
السريع في الخرطوم وانظر مان وتصدت قوه
الدعم السريع لغارات شنها طيران الجيش على
مواقعها في محيط القياده العامه والقصر
الجمهوري بالخرطوم فيما سمع دوي تبادل
لاطلاق نارا في هذه المناطق هذا هو مشطات
قوه الجيش مناطق في محيط مطر الخرطوم
الدولي وفي بحر شمال الخرطوم جددت
الطائرات الحربيه قصفها اهدافا للدعم
السريع في ضحيه كافوري شرقيه بحري وقال
الدعم السريع انه رد على الهجوم ويتمكن من
احباط الهجوم على معسكرها وكبد الجيش
خسائر كبيره وفي يندرمان غرب الخرطوم
افادت المعلومات بقصف طيران الجيش منطقه
صالحه ومناطق قريبه من سوق ليبيا حيث تقع
تمركزات الدعم السريعه
[موسيقى]
مبروك مبروك الله مبروك الله
مبروك مبروك
[موسيقى]
وفي اخر التطورات المواقف الدوليه قال
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه قال ان واشنطن
تعمل مع الامم المتحده للتوصلي لوقف اطلاق
النار في السودان وللمساعده في تحقيق
الانتقال الديمقراطي هناك جاء ذلك خلال
لقائه الامين العام للامم المتحده
نعمل عن قرب مع الامم المتحده على الازمه
في السودان ونامل ان نتمكن من التوصل لوقف
اطلاق النار ووقف العنف والمساعده في
ارجاع السودان الى مسار الانتقال الى
حكومه مدنيه نتعامل مع وضع انساني صعب جدا
هناك ويتفاقم
ومع استمرار خرق الهدنه المعلنه اعلنت
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه عن دعمها الكامل
لانهاء العنف في السودان مسؤوله بالوزاره
قالت انها بحثت مع قائد الجيش الوطني
لبيخل
ضروره منع الجهات الخارجيه ومن بينها
مجموعه فاجنر روسيه من زعزعه استقرار
شيراني ليبيا بما في ذلك السودان
اما روسيا فقد دعت هي الاخرى اطراف النزاع
الى ضبط النفس الناطقه باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا زخروفه دعت الى
اتخاذ خطوات عاجله لوقف اطلاق النار وقالت
ان الاحداث الماساويه التي يشهدها السودان
تثير قلق موسكو التي تتخذ كافه الاجراءات
اللازمه لضمان سلامه رعاياها في السودان
وبامكانيه تنفيذ اجراءات الاجلاء
هذا وناشد مواطن سوداني طرفي الصراع لوقف
الحرب والاقتتال وللعوده الى طاوله الحوار
نستمع
السيد البرهان والسيد حميد تبي انني يوقف
الحرب يا جماعه نسبه لتعب الشعبي
وللمعاناه التي عاناها الشعب السوداني
الذي لم يستحق هذه المعاناه يا جماعه
ارجوكم رد خاص اقعدوا في طاوله بتاعت حوار
وكل خلافات كل لان خلافاتكم شخصيه يا
جماعه
يا جماعه ربنا ده سبحانه وتعالى هيحاسبكم
على ما فعلتوه في الدنيا وفي الاخره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
القتال في اقليم دارفور غربيه السودان وفي
عاصمه الاقليم مدينه الجنينه واسفرت عن
مقتل العشرات واصابه اخرين واظهر مقطع
فيديو صوره احد السكان في الجنينه دخانا
اسود يتصاعد في الهواء وصوت اطلاق نار
كثيف وقال السكان للشبكات الجديده استهدفت
المدنيين في الجنينه التي تشهد نزاعا
قبليا عنيفا وفرارا للالافل الحدود
السودانيه
[تصفيق]
متابعه هذا الموضوع مع ضيفنا من الخرطوم
لواء الدكتور او ان الاتصال فصل مع ضيفنا
سنعود له بعد قليل سنستكمل بعض الاخبار
ذات الصله وفيما بعد نعود للضيف ونناقش
معه كل هذه التطورات الميدانيه مع احتدام
المواجهات بين الجيش والدعم السريع عبر
اهالي في مدينه ام درمان عن مخاوفهم من
استمرار عمليه السلب والنهبه واظهرت لقطته
فيديو خاصه بالعربيه مشاهد تظهر اغلاق
المحلات التجاريه في الاسواق الرئيسيه مع
اعاده فتح عدد قليل منها فيما يطالب
الاهالي الحكومه بتوفير الحمايه اللازمه
وبتامين حياه السكان في ام درمان ووقفي
واعمل العنف
واي شارع فيها ناصر شغالين شغل مره كسروا
دكاكيف
[موسيقى]
كله
جميع السوق يعني الناس
تقوم من هنا
لكن الوضع سيء سيء للدرجه بعيده وخلاص في
السوق
نعود الى ضيفنا من الخرطوم اللواء الدكتور
امين اسماعيل مجذوب الخبير الامني
والاستراتيجي بمركز الدراسات الدوليه
دكتور امين اهلا بك معنا دكتور امين كنا
نتحدث عن بعض المنشدات والتصريحات وحضرتك
تعلم بانها انطلقت منذ اليوم الاول من
الازمه السودانيه
جهات دوليه واماميه تطالب بوقف تام لاطلاق
النار ولكن الاشتباكات لا زالت مستمره وان
كانت بوتيره اخف ولكن الخرطوم نزلت مشتعله
في بعض المناطق هل نفهم بان الميدان الارض
هي من ستقرر ان كان سيكون هناك مفاوضات
فيما بعد ام لا
مساء الخير مرحب بك ومرحب بالساده
المشاهدين
حقيقه هذه المناشدات والوساطات الدوليه
لاسر كبير في انجاح بعض الفترات الغنه
اللي استمرت حوالي 72 ساعه
رغم الخروعات لكن فتحت مسارات انسانيه
للمستشفيات للجرحى للمرضى
وبالتالي الاشتباكات الموجوده الان واضح
انه الكفه تميل للقوات المسلحه قوات الدعم
السريع اتجهت الى المناطق السكنيه تحتملها
الى الاطراف في محاوله لاثبات الوجود انا
اعتقد انه دي الساعات الاخيره للتفاوض
يعني ساعات الاخيره كل طرف بيحاول يقوي
موقف والتفاوضي يدخل الى الهدنه الطويله
عواف يطلع النار وهو في مواقف مريحه وفي
وضع استراتيجي يمكن خاصه القوات المسلحه
من اعاده الحياه الى طبيعته وبالتالي
بتضمن سعر الحياه بجانب اطلاق النار
دكتور اسماعيل اسمحلي ابقى معي ينضم لنا
كذلك في هذه المتابعه وهذا التحليل من
الخرطومه الصحفي والمحلل السياسي احمد
خليل سيد احمد اهلا بك معنا كنت استمع
للدكتور امين هو بحسب قراءته يرى بان هذه
الاشتباكات المتفارقه هي نوع من الضغط
لمسك الارض ولتحديد كذلك سيطرت كل طرف على
المناطق التي يحتاجها حتى يفرض نوعا من
الشروط اذا ما وصلنا لمرحله المفاوضات الى
اي مدى تتفق مع ضيفي وان كانت هناك
مفاوضات كذلك السؤال الاهم ما الذي سيطلب
من نقاط التي ستطرح
انا اتمنى انه يكون هنالك مفاوضات اتمنى
ان نستفيد من هذه الهدنه لايقاف
اطلاق النار بين الطرفين
الطرفين هم غير مؤخرين اثبتوا اقلال هذه
الايام الماضيه انهم غير مؤهلين لوجود في
قياده القوات المسلحه الدعم السريع لانه
فرزته الحرب اول الاشتباكات هي خسائر
للشعب السوداني فبالتالي انا ارى بانه مسك
الارض هو يفيد مثلا يعني جيوش متحاربه
فيما بينها يعني في دول دول الدوله لدوله
ولكن داخل دوله ما هي يعني
الميزه التي يعني مثلا تمنع الدعم السريعي
ان هو ماسك على الارض اكثر من
استاذ احمد يقال بانه هذه طريقه من طرق
فرص امر واقع وفيما بعد في مرحله اخرى
تثبيت بعض النقاط لطرح شروط تكون شبه
مقبوله لانه الارض يكون ماسكها طرف من هذه
الاطراف الى اي مدى هذه القراءه قادرا
تكون دقيقه
هي غير قادره ان تكون دقيقه لانه مسك
الارض بمعنى انت ستكون محتل هذه الارض
ولكن الاراضي الان التي يتم فيها
المناوجات هي اغلبها اراضي للمواطنين او
مؤسسات حكوميه للشعب السوداني وهي ليس
للدعم السريع الجيش السوداني هي اراضي
للمواطنين السودانيين وهذا حق يعني
فبالتالي
قوتين يفترض ان يخرجوا من هذه الاراضي
دكتور
الحديث الاهم حتى لو في مفاوضات لابد ان
يكون هناك حديث في كيفيه دمج الدعم السريع
في الجيش ان يكون هنالك جيش واحد هو هذا
المهم يعني أنا قد تبدو هذه مرحله متقدمه
جدا استاذ احمد يعني
الدمج طريقه الدمج ستاتي بعض جلوس الاطراف
للتفاوض خلينا نفهم ان كانت هناك
نيه حقيقيه للتفاوض دكتور امين الاطراف
ستتفاوض على ماذا في هذه المرحله
الاولى ستكون لايقاف النار
[موسيقى]
منع القوات من الاشتباك مره اخرى هذا
الجند الاول الذي سيتم التفاوض عليه وضع
مراقبين من الوسطاء سواء كان هم متحده او
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اسمح لي
السؤال باي شروط يعني ما شروط التي
سيطرحها كل طرف وما المكاسب التي
يطمح في ان تكون له من خلال هذه المفاوضات
طبعا
هو طبعا دي بتيجي في
منضده التفاوض يعني اولا الناس يجلس بدون
شروط مصبره بعد كده يتم وقف اطلاق النار
بعد كده كله طلب بيطرح وجهه نظره لماذا
دخل هذا الاجتباك وتحديدا الدعم السريع
لماذا دخلت الاشتباك وترفض الدمج بالقوات
المسلحه وبالتالي تتجه الجميع بعد ذلك الى
مساله الحل
لجذور المشكله الجذور المشكله هي كانت
الدمج وتسويه السياسيه لذلك اذا تم
الاتفاق على وفاه اطلاع النار انا لا
اعتقد انه ستاخذ وقت طويل الى ان يتم
الاتفاق على الدم دي بتوقيتات زمنيه
محدده ودمج الدعم السريع والانتهاء من
مساله تعدد الجيوش هذه لن يسمح بها مهما
انتهت نتيجه الاشتباكات لن يسمح بوجود
اكثر من جيش وطني في السودان لذلك الاول
والجند الاخر سيكون معالجه جذور المشكله
وهي تمت عليه مواد الدعم السريع ولو انه
الدعم السريع يقول من خلال تصريحاته بان
الجيش السوداني هو من ورطنا في هذا الحرب
الموضوع ليس موضوع دمج واساسا نحن كنا
نقبل بهذه الخطوه والقوات المسلحه
السودانيه من جهتها كذلك تتهم بنفس هذه
الاتهامات الدعم السريع ولكن استاذ احمد
هل تعتقد بان الموضوع يمكن ان يطرح بهذه
الطريقه بان ياتي ضغط بان يجلس الاطراف
على طويله التفاوض ويتم فيما بعد محاوله
تاسيس لنقاط يتفق عليها هذه
هذه الاطراف او انه الوضع في الداخل
السوداني وضع اعقد من ذلك بكثير
طبعا الوضع في الداخل السوداني وضع معقد
جدا يعني الان ما يحدث على الارض هو عكس
ما يعني
ينقل الوضع في السودان الان هنالك كارثه
انسانيه كبيره اشياء السوداني الان يتعرض
الى القتلى المنهج بالاضافه الى تردي بيئي
بالاضافه الى اهم شيء هو نفس في الغذائيه
يعني يمكن خلال
اقل من اسبوع يمكن ان تنفس
الكميات الغذاء في الخرطوم لانه الخرطوم
هي المركز الصناعي والتجاري والتخزيمي في
السودان كل السودان يعني يجلب كل المواد
الغذائيه
واحتياجاته من الخرطوم يعني المصانع هي
الموجوده في الخرطوم فبالتالي الان هذه
المصانع هي كلها توقفت
هذه المصانع لا يوجد يعني تخزين او مخ
مؤمنه لان هذه المخازن تم يعني حرقها تم
ضربها تم يعني سرقتها فبالتالي احنا الان
في مازق كبير الجانب الانساني سيكون هو
واحده من الضغوطات التي تؤجل
بايقاف الحرب وايقاف الهدنه ووقف اطلاق
النار بين الطرفين طالما هم الطرفين
يتحدثون بانهم هم انطلقوا في هذه الحرب او
في هذه المناوشات من اجل المواطن السوداني
من اجل التحول الديمقراطي هكذا يقولون في
في بياناتهم وبالتالي صحيح يعني الطرفين
يتشاركان في مثل هكذا تصريحات ولكن ساعود
لك بخصوص نقاط اخرى ذات صله استاذ احمد
تفضل بالبقاء معي وكذلك الدكتور امين تفضل
معي ضيوفي الكرام نذكر ببعض الاخبار ذات
اصيله ومن ثم نعود من جديد الى تحليل كل
هذه التطورات في اخر المواقف الدوليه قال
وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه قال ان الوضع في
السودان قد يتفاقم في الايام المقبله كما
اكد على ان بلاده ستواصل الدعم للرعايه
البريطانيه
وقف اطلاق النار ليس مقدمه بالضروره
للسلام والوضع في السودان من الممكن ان
يتفاقم في الايام المقبله ونحن سنواصل
الدعم للرعايه البريطانيين لذلك نحن
موجودون في بورتسودان ولدينا مسؤولون
دبلوماسيون في مصر واثيوبيا والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه
قبل ذلك كان دعاك
البريطانيه في السودان الى الالتحاق
برحلات الجويه دون تاخير مشيرا الى ان
بريطانيا قد لا تكون قادره على مواصله
عمليات الاجلاء عندما ينتهي وقف اطلاق
النار
حان الوقت للتحرك لدينا الطائرات والقدرات
وايضا هدنه لوقف اطلاق النار لذلك نقول
للناس اذا كنتم تريدون الحصول على دعمنا
للسفر خارج السودان فافعلوا ذلك الان
يمكننا تسهيل خروجكم ربما سيقرر بعض
الاشخاص لاسباب خاصه البقاء حتى عندما يتم
وقف اطلاق النار لكننا نقول هناك رحلات
جويه واذا كنت ترغب في السفر فهذا هو افضل
وقت للقيام بذلك
وفي متابعه الاوضاع الصحيه المتردده قال
المدير الاقليمي لمنظمه الصحه العالميه
لشرق المتوسط الدكتور احمد المنظري قال ان
الهجمات على البنيه تحتيه الصحيه في
السودان تتصاعد مع سيطره اطراف النزاع على
المستشفيات في الخرطوم ونشد المنظر عبر
تغريده له على تويتر اطراف النزاع الاخلاء
الفوري لجميع المرافق الصحيه وعدم اعاقه
وظائف الصحه العامه الحيويه
تحذير امامي من كارثه صحيه في السودان 24
الف امراه سيلدن دون رعايه صحيه 50 الف
طفل يواجهون مخاطر حقيقيه
احدى وستون في المئه من المنشات الصحيه
مغلقه
16% من المرافق الصحيه تمارس عملها
المراكز المخصصه لمنع تفشي الاوبئه توقفت
عن العمل مع امكانيه وقوع اصابات بسبب شرب
مياه غير صالحه تسجيل 16 هجمه على مراكز
المنظمه الطبيه ومقتل ثمانيه اشخاص
الاستيلاء على مختبر طبي يثير مخاوف فمن
مخاطر بيولوجيه والتلاعب بالعينات
المخزونه
ومشاهدينا في اخر حصيله لاعداد الضحايا
جراء الاشتباكات اكدت نقابه اطباء السودان
ان ثلاثه اطفال لقوا حتفهم في مدينه
الاوبيض بشمال كردفان نتيجه في شهر قذيفه
وقالت ان عدد القتلى ارتفع الى 3 اشخاص
اثر استمرار تبادل اطلاق النار المستمر في
حين سجلت النقابه اصابات بلغت الف وثمانم
حاله بين المدنيين منذ بدايه الصراع موضحه
ان العديد من الاصابات والوفيات غير
مشموله في هذه الاحصائيات لعدم تمكنها من
الوصول للمستشفيات بسبب صعوبه التنقل
والوضع الامني في البلاد
وفي اخر التطورات الجهود دوليه لاحتواء
الازمه في السودان تلقى وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان اتصالا من
نظيرته الالمانيه
حول تطورات في السودان واكد الوزيران
اهميه وقف التصعيد العسكري في السودان
وتوفير الحمايه اللازمه للمدنيين
السودانيين وللمقيمين على ارضه وتوفير
الممرات الانسانيه الامنه للراغبين في
مغادره الاراضي السودانيه
ومع تعاقد الوضع في الخرطوم اصبح الحصول
على صور تظهر حجم دمار امرا نادرا وكاله
رويترز نشرت مجموعه من الصور المتفرقه
التي تم التقاطها اليوم لاثار المعارك في
الخرطوم بحري حيث تظهر هذه الصور مشاهد
الدمار بشكل كبير اثر المعارك دعونا نتابع
هذه الصور مشاهدينا والتي نشرتها رويترز
نعود من جديد الى ضيوفنا لمتابعه وتحليل
200 عليه من اخبار رواد الدكتور امين
اسماعيل مجدوب الخبير الامني هو
الاستراتيجي بمركز الدراسات الدوليه ومن
الخرطومه صحفي والمحلل السياسي احمد خليل
اسمحوا لي ان ابدا معك استاذه احمد فيما
يخص ما كنا انهينا به كلامنا منذ قليل عن
الحاله في الواقع الانسانيه الصعبه التي
يعيشها داخل السوداني وحضرتك اعلم بهذه
التفاصيل وتدرك بان السودان
كان عاش اكثر من ازمه واكثر من حرب وه
اساسا حاله انسانيه صعبه يعيش السودان ما
المخاوف التي تحيط بهذه هذا البلد اذا ما
تطورت او استمرت هذه الاشتباكات
طبعا
الاساسيه التي تشير على المواطن السوداني
نفس الغذاء اذا نقص الغذاء في الخرطوم
سيتحول المواطن السوداني من المواطن عادي
الى مواطن يبحث الغذاء لاشرته فقط يضطر
للحفاظ على اسرته بالدفاع عن هذه الاسره
وجلب غذاء باي طريقه يعني يمكن ان يعني
تولد عنف بين المواطنين للحصول على
الالقاء فموضوع الندره تقلب الندره في
مساله في
فيتم الطلب عليها علي سيكون المنافسه على
هذه السلعه عالي جدا انا ذكرت في حديثي في
البدايه ان الخرطوم هي مركز تجاري ومركز
الصناعي مركز لكل لكل لكل الفعاليات
الاقتصاديه في السودان خاصه الصناعات
الغذائيه فبالتالي
حتى يعني جلب
الغذاء من خارج الخرطوم من الولايات
سيواجه صعوبات يعني يمكن ان يتم استيلاء
المواد القادمه من الولايات من قبل الجيش
او من قبل الدعم السريع او من قبل
المتفلتين فبالتالي هذه واحده من المشكله
يا استاذه احمد حتى السيطره على
المستشفيات وفي هذا الاطار كنا تحدثنا منذ
قليل او تابع
نا فالشاشه
بعض ذات الصله فيما يخص هذا الموضوع
الخارجيه السودانيه كانت دعت الامم
المتحده لمطالبه دعم السريع بالانسحاب من
المرافق الصحيه وتقول الخارجيه السودانيه
باننا سلمنا اي الخارجيه طبعا بانها سلمت
الصحه العالميه مذكره حول تعدي الدعم
السريع على مستشفيات بالخرطوم وفي هذا
الاطار اسال الدكتور امين دكتور امين
حضرتك منذ قليل تحدثت على وجوب ان تتابع
وتراقب الامم المتحده والجهات الامميه
ما يحدث اما فيما يخص وقفه اطلاق النار او
كذلك فيما يخص حمايه المنشات ولكن كيف
يمكن ان يتم ذلك مع هذه الشبكات المتقطعه
وكل طرف يقول بان طرف الاخر هو الذي لا
يحترم او لا يلتزم وقف اطلاق النار حضرتك
من خلال تجربتك كامني وكخبير استراتيجي
الى اي مدى يمكن للامم المتحده ان تتابع
وان
تضمن حمايه هذه المنشات
اذا لم تكن هنالك ارا
ده المبادرات لا بد من وجود اراده ووجود
صيغه بين الطرفين لاغاف هذه الاشتباكات
اذا عجزت الامم المتحده والمجتمع الدولي
عن غناء الطرفين هنالك مبدا في بنود
الالفيه الثالثه يتحدث عن التدخل لاسباب
انسانيه وهذا ما يخشاه جميع الان لانه
التدخل معناها
تدخل
دوليات للفصل بين الجانبين وبالتالي تتكرر
تجارب في افريقيا وفي عدد من الدول
العربيه ولدينا في السودان تجربه
اليوناميت في دارفور جلست هذه القوات
حوالي 25 عام
عندما دخلت للفص بين المتنازعين في فلين
دارفور لذلك يجب على الطرفين ان يقراوا
المساله جيدا يضع الخيارات جيدا يختاروا
افضل المسالك الموجوده حتى لا يدخلوا في
في هذا النفق لانه
تحدثت حضرتك بخصوصه عن المخاوف من ان يكون
هناك تدخل دولي يوقف الاقتتال او يضمن
وقفا دائم لهذا الاقتتال هل حضرتك هذه
المخاوف يعني تعتقد بانها قائمه على
دلائل على مؤشرات حقيقيه او ان الموضوع
مستبعد تماما في هذه المرحله
ما زالت الفرصه الان لدى لدى الطرفين طبعا
هم صرحوا كل الطرف صرح بانه يريد ان ان
خيارات صفريه تجاه الطرف الاخر وهذا الامر
كان مقبول في الايام الاولى لكن الان نحن
في نهايه الاسبوع الثاني وربما ندخل في
الاسبوع الثالث لذلك المبدا الدولي يقول
انه اي نظام او حكومه لا تراعى الانسان
في حالات السلم او في حالات النزاعات
والحروب يتدخل العالم لفرض السلم والامن
ايضا الموقع للسوداني يهمه المجتمع الدولي
لانه يؤثر على كل الاظلم من دول الساحل
حتى دول شرق افريقيا وهي اصلا تعاني يعني
الجوار الغربي السوداني بها اربع دول
لديها ازمات وفي شركه السودان هنالك
دولتين ازمات وحروبات كانت قبل قبل شهور
لذلك العالم اعتقد انه يمنح الفرصه الان
هنالك اتصالات هنالك محاولات لكن السعاده
الاخيره يكون هنالك التزام ومراعاه
للنواحي الانسانيه وللشعب السوداني حتى لا
يضطر العالم الى التدخل الدولي
استاذه احمد بعض الاخبار كذلك التي
تابعناها منذ قليل اسفل الشاشه اتت من
الحكومه البريطانيه التي اكدت بان سفير
بريطانيا في السودان يتحدث عن او مع طرفي
النزاع لاحاثهما على تمديد الهدنه وبان
الحكومه البريطانيه تضغط لتمديد وقفي
اطلاق النار في السودان وبالتالي السيد
احمد سؤال بما يمكن ان تضغط الحكومه
البريطانيه حضرتك اعلم بعلاقات السودان
الدوليه ما الملفات التي يمكن ان تكون
قادره بريطانيا ان تضغط بها على الطرفين
لمحاوله فرض وقف اقتتال دائم
[موسيقى]
الصحفيه المحلله السياسي احمد خليل شكرا
لك وشكر كذلك لضيفي من الخرطوم الدكتور
امين اسماعيل مجدوب الخبير الامني
والاستراتيجيه بمركز الدراسات الدوليه
شكرا جزيلا لك ومشاهدينا ننتقل مباشره الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في جده ومراسل
العربيه هاني الصيان هاني اهلا بك معنا
ساعات مستمره متواصله منذ الامس تبعناك مع
وصول الباخره النفطيه الصينيه وحتى الان
كذلك ساعات متسارعه لاستقبال رعايه اخرين
حدثنا عن الصوره الكلمه لك وصوره كذلك معك
نعم ووتيره العمل ووصول الاسطول من السفن
ووتيره العمل ايضا على الجسر الجوي تزايدت
امر مختلف عن اليومين الماضيين كانت سفينه
تبعتها ثلاث سفن وبعد ذلك ست سفن واليوم
نتحدث عن سبع سفن ما بين سفن تابعه للقوات
البحريه الملكيه السعوديه وبين ايضا
فرقاطات عسكريه لبعض الدول الاسيويه وكذلك
ايضا هناك في قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه
وايضا هي في جده ايضا جسر جوي من مختلف
الطيران العسكري في جميع دول العالم تنقل
رعاياها او ايضا تقوم بجلب برعاياها من
السودان الى جده اذا مدينه جده اصبحت هي
المكان الامن الان بالنسبه لرعايه
الجنسيات المختلفه والبالغه عددهم والذين
وصلوا تحديدا الى جده من تسعه وستين جنسيه
هذه سفينه اخرى ولكنها سفينه جلاله الملك
الرياض التابعه للقوات البحريه الملكيه
السعوديه هي اليوم تقوم بنقل 200 شخص من
رعايه من جنسيات مختلفه تقوم بالوقوف الان
على الرصيف المعد لها وكذلك من قبل منسوبي
القوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه والذين
يقومون الان بمد هذا الجسر الى
ظهر السفينه ليتم نزول رعايه الجنسيات
المختلفه والتي تم وصول هذه السفينه من
بورتسودان قبل قليل اذا هذه اللحظات
الاولى التي ترصدها كاميرا العربيه للوصول
سفينه جلاله الملك الرياض الى
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في مدينه
جده هناك طبعا اعداد كبيره واضح جدا وايضا
بعض القنصليات
وكذلك بعض السفراء هم حاضرين هنا من اجل
استقبال رعاياها
سوف ما هي جنسيات تحدثنا عن عمليه اجلال
ما يقرب عن الاثنين والخمسين دبلوماسياتهم
تقريبا
نعم نحن نتحدث الان عن جنسيات معظمها من
اسيا نتحدث عن اندونيسيا تايلاند بعض
الدول الافريقيه وكذلك ايضا بعض الدول
الاوروبيه هم يحضرون على متن هذه السفينه
وسوف تتضح لنا الجنسيات بشكل ادق وتفصيل
اكثر عند نزول هؤلاء الرعايه دعينا نتحدث
اليوم عن صعوبه الامر الان في بورت سودان
بحسب حديث شهود عيان وكذلك ايضا بحسب
الرعايه السابقين والذين تم المقابله معهم
سواء هنا في الاسطول البحري هنا في قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه او كذلك في ميناء جده
الاسلامي او ايضا في قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه كانوا يتحدثون انه هناك المزيد من
الجنسيات المختلفه ولكن لا يجدون من يقوم
باجلاهم سواء من خروجهم من بورسودان الى
بلدانهم او ايضا على ظهر السفينه
شاهدناه ايضا هناك ان العديد من
خلال شهود عيان الرعايه ان هناك العديد
ممن قالوا ان الوضع متازم انسانيا وان
ايضا
كانوا يمكثون مده تجاوزت الاربعه ايام حتى
حصلوا على سفن تجربهم اليوم عندما كنا
نرصد او خلال الفتره الماضيه عندما كانت
شاشه العربيه ترصد السفن التي كانت تصل
الى ميناء جده الاسلامي او الى هنا في
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه فكنا نشاهد
الفرقاطات العسكريه للدول المتنوعه كانت
فقط تنقل رعاياها باستثناء السفن السعوديه
تابع للقوات البحريه او كذلك الطيران
التابع للقوات الجويه الملكيه السعوديه
الذي كان ينقل الرعايه من جنسيات مختلفه
الامر الان عند وصولهم هناك مراحل متتابعه
هناك صعوبات ولكن تم ايضا تدليلها من قبل
الحكومه السعوديه خاصه ان معظم هؤلاء
الرعايه لا يملكون التاشيره الدخول التي
تمكنهم ايضا من المغادرات او مغادره
السعوديه الى بلدانهم فيمنح لهم تاشيره
طوارئ بشكل سريع حتى يتمكنون من الدخول
الى الاراضي السعوديه وكذلك مغادرتها خلال
اليومين القادمين بعد التنسيق ما سفراتهم
وقنصلياتهم الموجوده هنا في مدينه جده
عموما ما زلنا في الدقائق معدوده نقوم
بالدخول بشكل
ملفت من قبل المصور يلتقدنا بعض الصور
صحيح سنبقى مع هذه الصور وسننتظر نزول من
وصل الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في جده
ممكن سؤال قد يتبادر لاذهان كثيرين لماذا
لا اتحدث عن بواخر السعوديه التي تجري
رعايا دول اخرى هذا مفهوم المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ببواخرها ستجلي الى جده الى جده
ولكن هناك بواخر لدول اخرى يعني لغه هي
باخره فرنسيه اختارت ان ترسو في جده هناك
اعتقد كذلك باخره بريطانيه اختارت ان تتجه
الى جده او ذكرني ان كانت هناك دول اخرى
دول اوروبيه اختارت انت اتجاه وترسو في
جده هل لانه جغرافيه الميناء اقرب الى
السودان ام لانه هناك
اجواء من المساعده والتامين حدثنا اكثر عن
هذه النقطه لو سمحت
كابتن فرقاء الفرقاطه الفرنسيه اندريه كنت
اسال هذا السؤال كان يحمل على متنه سفينته
العسكريه لورين اكثر من 400 شخص وجميعهم
من رايه الامم المتحده ونفس السؤال الذي
كنت اطرحه ايضا على السيد الطيب ادم وهو
ممثل الامم المتحده للطفوله كنت اتحدث في
البدايه مع السيد الطيب قلت له كنا دائما
ما نعلم ونعرف ان الامم المتحده هي من
تقوم باجلاء جميع الرعايه الجنسيات في
المناطق المنكوبه او الصراعات هذه المره
الان الفرقات الفرنسيه هي تقوم بجلب او
اجلاء رعاياكم والقدوم بهم الى جده وكنت
ايضا اسال السيد لوري السيد اندريه كابتن
فرقاطه لورين كنت اساله لماذا لم يتجه هذا
هؤلاء الرايه الى بلدانهم طبعا هو كان
جوابه ان هناك جنسيات مختلفه
قال لي انا انا احمل على امتني سفينتي
اكثر من 62 جنسيه من بعثات الامم المتحده
كان الاقرب لي والاسهل والامن بالنسبه
ممرات المائيه التي امنتها لي القوات
البحريه الملكيه السعوديه ان اتجه الى جده
وبعد ذلك يتم مغادره هؤلاء الجنسيات عبر
مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي جوا اسهل
بالنسبه للرايه وكذلك اسهل في عمليه
الاجراءات السيد الطيب ادم عندما سالته
ايضا لماذا لم تقوم بعثه الامم المتحده
والامم المتحده لماذا لم تقوم باجلاء
الرعايه الموجودون هناك فقال لي ان الوضع
صعب جدا ولم نستطيع حصر الاعداد بل لم
نستطيع ايضا التحرك داخل السودان بسبب عدم
الوضع الامن وعدم استقرار هذا الامر حتى
هذه النقطه في كل الحالات هاني سنعود لك
في اطار هذه التغطيه بعد بدء نزول الرعايه
الرعايه الدول المختلفه من او في قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه في جده اود شكرك جزيل
الشكر هاني على كل ما تتفضل به في كل
مداخله من تفاصيل ومن تطورات من عندك شكرا
جزيلا
ومشاهدينا بددد النزاع العسكري امال
ملايين المواطنين بانتهاء عقود الحصار
والفقر والاستبداد في السودان حيث تسببت
المعارك الدائره بين قوات الدعم السريع
والجيش بخسائر اقتصاديه مباشره فادحه تقدر
بمليارات الدولارات مع خسائر اخرى غير
مباشره قد يطول امدها في حال لم يتواصل
الطرفان الى اتفاق قريب لوقف اطلاق النار
متابع
ما ان اطلقت اول رصاصه في مطار الخرطوم
الدولي حتى خسر السودان خمسه في المئه من
اجمالي صادراته ووارداته مليارات دولار من
عائدات صادرات الذهب توقفت هي الاخرى مثل
ما توقفت الحركه التجاريه مع مصر ملايين
الدولارات تتبعثر مع كل قذيفه تفجر مبنى
او تنسف جسرا انها ضريبه الحرب التي
يدفعها المواطنون
المشكله بقى خطير علينا يا جماعه
المواطنين وعايشين عايشين ظروف
فيها ان لم تهدا المدافع ستدخل البلاد في
فوضى عارمه يحذر الخبراء من مجاعه تطال
الجميع
وحتى ان توقفت الحرب لن يعود التمويل
الدولي بسهوله ولا ثقه المستثمرين ولن
يعود هؤلاء النازحون لدفع عجله التنميه
السودانيه طالما ان بلد ثروات بلا استقرار
سياسي
[موسيقى]
ومشاهدينا الاكيد باننا سنبقى في متابعه
هذه التطورات وتغطيه الخاصه بالازمه
السودانيه ولكن ننهي هذه الساعه بموجز
لاخر واهم الاخبار الدوليه وفي اخر
التطورات كانت رحبت موسكو باي خطوات قد
تسهم في انهاء النزاع في اوكرانيا هذا
واكد المتحدث باسم الكريم انه ليس على
درايه بما يتداولته وسائل الاعلام بشان
محاوله الهيئات الامنيه الاوكرانيه اغتيال
بوتين باستخدام مسيره مشيرا لان العلاقات
مع دول الاوروبيه عند ادنى مستواها ياتي
هذا بعد اعلان الهيئات الامنيه الاوكرانيه
بانها قد ساعدت لتنظيم محاوله اغتيال
للرئيس الروسي
من جهتها اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن
اصابه جميع اهدافها عقب توجيه ضربه مركزه
باسلحه بحريه عاليه الدقه على مواقع
التمركز احتياطات القوات الاوكرانيه وفي
سياق ذاتها فدت الدفاع الروسيه ان قوتها
قامت بسيطره على عده مناطق جديده في
الضواحي الشماليه والجنوبيه لباخموت مؤكده
على ان الجيش الروسي ابسط سيطرته على
اربعه احياء جديده في باخموت
شددت الخارجيه الروسيه على ان التنفيذ
الكامل للاتفاق المبرم هو الحل الوحيد
لانقاذ صفقه الحبوب في البحر الاسود
واضافت الخارجيه الروسيه ان جهود الامم
المتحده وحده وحدها ليست كافيه لان قرار
صفقه الحبوب يعتمد على نتائج عمل الوكالات
الحكوميه المختلفه وهي ليست صفقه يمكن
الاختيار منها او تركها
اكدا وزير الخارجيه الصينيه تشينج ان اول
محادثه هاتفيه بين رئيس الصيني مع نظيره
الاوكرانيه
العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه تعد خطوه مهمه
نحو تسويه سياسيه للازمه مشيرا الى ان
الخطوه التي اتخذتها الصين تمثل مدى
التزام الدوله الثابت بالحياديه قائلا ان
موقف الصيني يعزز عمليات السلامه
والمفاوضات
قالت المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الصينيه مو نيند قالت في بيان لها ان
امريكا تقوم بتحقيق مصالحها الجو السياسيه
الشخصيه مستغله بذلك قضيه فنزويلا لزياده
التوتر في البلاد بحسب تعبيرها نستمع
من اجل تحقيق مصالحها الجيوسياسيه الشخصيه
تتجاهل الولايات المتحده الامن الاقليمي
وتصر على استغلال قضيه فنزويلا لزياده
التوتر ما تفعله امريكا حاليا يعتمد على
عقليه الحرب البارده ما يثير المواجهات
العسكريه ويضعف نظام منع انتشار الاسلحه
النوويه والمصالح الاستراتيجيه للدول
الاخرى ويؤدي الى تفاقم التوتر ويقوي
السلامه والاستقرار الاقليميين ويتعارض مع
هدف اخلاء البلاد من الاسلحه النوويه
وتعرض الصين ذلك بشده
اعلنت البحريه الامريكيه ان الحرس الثوريه
الايراني احتجز ناقله نفط ترفع علم جزر
مارشال مطالبه بالافراج الفوري عنها وقال
الوصول الخامس للبحريه الامريكيه ان الحرس
الثوريه الايرانيه احتجان ناقله النفط
اثناء عبورها في المياه الدوليه في خليج
عمان مطالبا الحكومه الايرانيه الى
الافراج عنها فورا بدورها قالت البحريه
الايرانيه ان الناقله حاولت الفرار بعد
اصطدامها بزورق ايراني ما اسفراء عن فقدان
شخصين واصابه اخرين مشيره لان مدمره
ايرانيه اوقفت ناقله وقتادتها للسواحل
الايرانيه
في تطور اخر اعلن وزير العدل البولندي ان
الاجهزه الامنيه تحقق في العثور على بقايا
جسم عسكريا جوي داخل غابه وسط البلاد وان
الاداره العسكريه بمكتب النائب العام في
مدينه جادانسك تقود تحقيق بمشاركه خبراء
عسكريين وعملاء مكافحه التجسس من الشرطه
والجيش فيما قالت وزاره الدفاع ان الجسم
الذي تم العثور عليه بالقرب من ذا موسكو
التي تبعد نحو 265 كيلومترا شمال غربي
وارسو لا يشكل خطرا على السكان
اكدا وزير الدفاع على بريطاني بين ولاس
اكد ان بلاده هو المانيا ستعملان معا في
المرحله التاليه من تطوير ذخيره قذيفه
خارقه للدروع فاتحا في الوقت ذاته رغبه اي
دوله اخرى في الانضمام لهذا التعاون مضيفا
ان تطوير ذخيره موحده لا يعني توطيد
التعاون في ساحه المعركه مع العديد من
الحلفاء في الناتو وانما يساهم ايضا في
مضاعفه امكانات التصدير وفي سبل الدفاع في
كلتا دولتين
مشاهدينا في الختام نعود لنستكمل تغطيه
احداث السودان مع الزميل الليالي بعد قليل
ولكن قبل ذلك متابع هذه الصور المتداوله
لاثر دمار وقتل في منطقه بري قرب القياده
العامه بعد دخول قوات الدعم السريع اليها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات